oil prices are surging with few signs of
slowing down brent crude oil the global
benchmark for energy markets surpassed
100 a barrel after russian president
vladimir putin ordered an attack on
ukraine
oil has climbed pretty rapidly over the
past year and it's climbing further with
russia's invasion of ukraine the main
reason why is there's a concern that
this conflict could disrupt energy
exports into global markets the supply
and demand dynamics have contributed to
the jump in oil prices and for consumers
when oil becomes more expensive so do
other goods and services here's how it
works
there's many different ways that the
energy
price rises we're seeing will feed into
higher inflation the cost of living in
the u.s rose to 7.5 percent in january
from a year earlier a nearly four decade
high economists at moody's analytics
estimate that inflation is costing the
average u.s household an additional 276
dollars a month this stems from higher
prices across a range of products
including gasoline the biggest reason
why gasoline prices went up is because
of oil and one of the biggest reasons
why inflation was so high was because of
gas prices americans are paying about
twice as much for gasoline now compared
to early in the covet 19 pandemic and
with demand for oil projected to
continue outstripping supply there's
little promise of relief ahead for u.s
households it's not just in what we pay
in gas at the pump but this really can
have a dramatic effect on all types of
price increases across the united states
for those hoping to take long postponed
vacations the increases in oil could
affect airfares while airline ticket
prices have stayed relatively stable
during the pandemic travel booking site
hopper forecasts an average seven
percent increase in domestic airfare
each month until june citing higher jet
fuel prices as one of the reasons
if oil goes up and airlines are paying
more for oil to power airplanes they're
going to raise prices on airfares sky
high fuel costs also affect the prices
of the food we grow in the ground
they'll feed into your plate because
remember we put a lot of ethanol into
our car and we need a lot of diesel to
plant and harvest farming and food
processing can be energy intensive
accounting for a significant share of
production costs farmers in the us will
spend an estimated 16 billion dollars on
fuel and oil in 2022
a 35 increase from 2020 this has
consequences for supermarket shoppers
who have already seen food prices
increase 7 percent since around this
time last year much of that increase can
be linked to the cost of getting food
from the farm to shelves the same can be
said for any other product that is moved
by ship train or truck oil is one of
those commodities that really feeds into
every part of the supply chain and
therefore impacts the inflation if
you're a business and you need to spend
more just to ship goods across the us
that's going to become more expensive
and often times businesses will pass on
those additional costs for that product
onto the consumer trucking companies and
other logistics firms have already been
dealing with higher costs which include
rising salaries in a tight labor market
and according to a survey conducted by
business research group the conference
board 72 percent of ceos of large u.s
companies said they expect to pass on
higher labor and transportation costs to
customers within the next 12 months
consumer spending accounts for more than
two-thirds of us gdp and if consumers
have to pay more for staples like food
and gasoline they might be forced to cut
spending on other items i don't think
anyone is expecting the economy to enter
a downturn because of this but i think
the idea is is that we're gonna have
slower economic growth than we did last
year in part because of oil prices but
it is sapping the economy of momentum
[Music]
you